[Musique]
c'est un beau village niché dans les
montagnes près du détroit d'Hudson salut
c'est le deuxième village le plus éloigné du
nord du Québec accessible uniquement par avion
[Musique]
il abrite près de 1 700 personnes fin
octobre 2013 l'hiver s'est déjà installé
dans un pick-up  le camion serpente lentement
sur la route de l'aéroport à l'intérieur de
deux jeunes filles inuites de 15 et 16 ans le
chauffeur est un homme blanc de 27 ans le
pick-up quitte la route de l'aéroport et se dirige
vers le dépotoir du village la nuit tombe
Sallu ça semble soudain loin  loin
le camion traverse la litière
puis s'arrête le silence est assourdissant
[Musique]
Kathy Papa il a pris voulait partager avec
ses mots ce qui s'est passé cette nuit-là elle a
accepté que nous vous disions son nom et
entendions sa voix mais elle a demandé que nous
brouiller son visage je ne m'en souvenais pas
vraiment mais je me souviens d'être à moitié nue sa
sœur Kalyn est sur la banquette arrière impuissante
j'essayais de
je suis d'abord allée à l'hôpital
puis après je suis allée y aller  au poste de
police, je pense qu'il s'appelle
Daniel
[Musique]
il y a Kathy et il y a beaucoup d'autres
femmes inuites maltraitées par des hommes blancs qui sont
venus dans le Nord pour travailler des femmes qui ont le
courage et toutes les raisons du monde de
dire un mot puissant
[  Musique]
Kathy Papa gotoku nous montre sa chambre
où son bébé de trois mois dort
paisiblement avoir sa propre chambre est un
luxe au Nunavut
c'est son refuge
sa vie a changé depuis la naissance de son petit
garçon elle ne boit plus ni ne fume de
marijuana pourquoi ça  était important de nous en parler
parce que vous décidez d'en
parler publiquement il vaut mieux en
parler en parler pour libérer l'obscurité
de l'ancre qu'à l'intérieur c'est
comme revivre dans le passé donc c'est mieux
qu'en 2013 Kathy papica a pris 15 ans
ans, elle se promène dans les rues de Salawat
avec sa sœur Kaylin, elle a un peu
trop bu où
l'ouvrier du bâtiment s'arrête-t-il et les invite-t-
il dans son camion pour faire un tour, il
était gentil la première fois  e que nous avons
vu de lui puis a commencé à parler il était du
genre à avoir ses amis mais il
s'est avéré que c'était un monstre Je me suis fait violer
dans la voiture
[Musique]
Je vends des choses pour parler c'est dans sa
langue Inuktitut la Kathi raconte
ce qui s'est passé  cette nuit-là, je sais que tu
étais à Lewiston mon amour même si
j'aime Sam j'aime ça je sais ce que la
salle de coupe
je n'ai pas besoin de le perdre le travailleur
les ramène ensuite au village et les
pousse hors du camion
c'est une question de timing
[Musique
] quelques jours plus tard Cathy porte plainte
au commissariat de Salavat des années
plus tard en 2017 elle se retrouverait
face à face avec son agresseur au tribunal un
moment difficile mais décisif que je
cachais un peu car j'étais nerveuse quand il a
vu  mon visage il n'était pas content de me voir
et je veux dire on était tous les deux pas contents de
se voir et je me cachais près de
ma mère
Daniel Bilodeau a plaidé coupable à un
chef d'agression sexuelle sur mineur dans
sa version de  événements Cathy lui a dit qu'elle
avait 20 ans il dit aussi qu'elle
c'est lui qui est venu vers lui et qu'il
n'y a pas eu de pénétration en août 2017
Vlado est condamné à 240 jours de prison
selon le procureur la peine
est appropriée
division cinquième dimanche incendie donc sciemment
défendre la constitutionnalité voir la société
avocate réputée
Elaine Arsenal a participé à l'
enquête sur
les femmes autochtones disparues et assassinées il connaît bien les
problèmes pour lui les commentaires des procureurs sont
troublants équité représentation défense
a no se puede herbe notre télévision
présentation d'Oussama Donna  si Allah Coran
Irizarry chez un homme ordinaire l'
agresseur de la Fed vient reste et l'
agression médicinale Allah progressivement plus de
mots de porc en télougou interdit à la lumière de la
déclaration des procureurs le juge président
jean-pierre job d'un exprime un certain
malaise
les gens à propos d'un certain degré au sujet de la
conséquence plus tard le juge clarifie
sa déclaration la conséquence une spe  ar
seulement des impôts justes mm acide il considère
Santa poinsettia Batson laisse la
victime comme si le si sexuellement célèbre était
un patron de cas une sonate padilha Burton
City conduit monoïde de pizza ils ne voient pas
sa présence déçu
Marcus ce n'est pas cet exemple Danielle
Villa pâte est maintenant  inscrit au
registre des délinquants sexuels et y restera
pendant 10 ans, il était censé être dans un
centre de réadaptation, mais lorsque nous y sommes allés
, les employés ne l'avaient pas vu depuis deux
jours, nous avons demandé
où il se trouvait actuellement, mais on nous a dit que l'
information est  confidentiel
Venable orné de Nikki allez
nous avons contacté son ancien employeur Ginny
construction ils n'étaient pas au courant de la conduite de leurs
anciens employés ils ont refusé
notre demande d'entrevue l'entreprise
déclare que les employés doivent suivre des
directives claires lorsqu'ils travaillent au Nunavik et
que la consommation d'alcool est interdite
après l'incident, la sœur de Kathy a quitté
Salawat Kaelin vit maintenant à Montréal
où elle cherche du travail
concr  ete les tunnels du métro ont remplacé
les grands espaces du nord
pourquoi voulez-vous parler je veux aider les
gens je ne sais pas par où commencer
les taux d'agressions sexuelles au Nunavik sont
alarmants selon les statistiques de 2017
fournies par la police régionale de karevik 220
cas impliquent  mineurs et 226 impliquent des
adultes pour une population d'un peu plus de
12 000 une femme sur trois a subi
une agression sexuelle dans son enfance ce ne sont que
les incidents signalés la plupart ne sont pas la
majorité des agresseurs sont des Inuits des
traumatismes passés l'abus d'alcool et de drogues ainsi que
des maisons surpeuplées contribuent tous  à cette
triste réalité, l'aîné du
kit de viol, nous voyons le plus une petite
situation difficile, nous ne savons pas Paula do
Sylvanus, il vient dans les ordres, je veux dire les
papiers casona d'accord depuis notre poche, la
récession de la poche est avec des fouets
ou un recours  une seconde oh tu t'occupes
encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mission octane est le chef de la police du Nunavik
il supervise la sécurité des 14
villages de la région un tiers de
Q  Territoire du uebec son mandat de trois ans
vient de se terminer le
chef de police vétéran est sorti de sa retraite pour
prêter main forte dans le nord selon
lui certains travailleurs qui viennent au Nunavik
exploitent la pollinisation des revenus vulnérables de l'Agence des services aux personnes handicapées
Giannini envoyé non appelé s  opération
Internacional mes spectacles de vente je vois ok
problème de baku-pod pas de Canada sur un bateau yakov en
público période familier facilement
opportunité mais un professeur principal
compétition une pomme de terre en Kelvin arabe donc
à l'Académie Mansfield paraphé j'appellerai
le médicament malheureusement plus chiffre jaune Seri
aide post e décision fan faible alcool
émousse la douleur le désespoir ça fait aussi
la mémoire seuls trois villages autorisent la
vente libre d'alcool dans les onze autres
il faut un permis pour l'importer encore l'
alcool est partout soumission l'IVC
/examens parler arabe du néerlandais  entre-
noeud coughlin putatif wasa tetani voir Patek
dizzy tongs ou petit Poisson géométrie
Lafleur a été policier pendant 14
ans en avec lui  a quitté la force en 2016,
il se souvient encore de l'un de ses premiers
appels à une caméra de construction, un homme dans
la quarantaine avait attiré une fille de 14 ans
dans sa chambre
m.  Davis un coup pas que toute
caméra de zone de texte a également mis en place notre costume révéler
quelque chose de visible ah mr.  Bostick Elka
montre que la jeune fille s'est enfuie à
l'arrivée de la police.
postérieur
peut-être criminel cetera bonjour
[Musique
] c'était une scène qui s'est répétée
nous vous donnons une hyperbole dindes Natalia
ongles comme l'Hôtel de la coop sur la
subvention échelle phonétique pouvoir
saisir un petit retour comme la peau Abby
Lee de l'hôtel dirigé ce sont
la Constitution Jane Clements travaille dans
le bar du porte-
manteau près de la côte d'Ungava c'est très quand les
hommes viennent ici pour l'été pour un travail
temporaire et ils pensent qu'ils ne pourraient pas
simplement ramener une fille du bar à la maison
et les coudre dans les rues  après avoir
fait tout ce qu'ils avaient à faire et j'ai
vu que de nombreuses fois quand j'étais célibataire,
ils essayaient d'en profiter, essayaient
de me demander de  suivez-les à la maison après le
bar que
jenipa Peggy a pris est originaire de Sol
LeWitt aujourd'hui, elle vit dans la Laurentienne
z-- avec ses trois enfants, cette
artiste accomplie était autrefois une jeune
adolescente traînant autour des
ouvriers de la construction jenny préfère ne pas faire face à notre
caméra c'est trop difficile elle
ressent toujours la honte que ça ne me dérange pas si je
vais être jugé ou si je vais être
méprisé J'ai fait ça pour protéger nos
enfants nos jeunes filles et pour éviter
la même chose qui est arrivée à beaucoup d'entre
nous chaque été elle  attendrions l'
arrivée des travailleurs, nous saurions
quand ils arrivent parce que c'est à chaque
saison et il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup d'hommes
qui ne sont pas de votre famille dans le Nord, alors
ces hommes venaient et ils
apportaient de l'alcool et puis nous étions restés et
on aurait l'impression wow il me choisit est ce
qu'ils viennent te chercher
parfois ils n'attendent même pas pour aller à
la
caravane  il lui a
fallu beaucoup de temps pour se rendre compte des dommages
qui avaient été causés, mais maintenant, si les filles peuvent
savoir que ce n'est pas bien, elles devraient
porter plainte ou elles devraient faire savoir aux gens
que ces gens font que des journées plus chaudes
marquent l'ouverture de la saison de construction
au Nunavik  le bruit des marteaux
résonne dans la plupart des 14 villages les
réparations les rénovations la construction de
nouveaux logements les besoins sont nombreux
l'arrivée du cargo signale
le début de toutes les activités dans lesquelles
n'étaient que l'un des on see rock and roll
down the ladders politique  structure nous
rencontrons jean-jacques Molly installé dans le nouveau
bâtiment de la propriété foncière de Salavat c'est la
propriété foncière qui délivre les permis aux
entreprises de construction en juillet dernier pour les
entreprises et leurs sous-traitants se sont
partagé le travail plus de 100 travailleurs se sont envolés
pour la ville
on nous dit que tous doivent suivre  un
code de conduite rien de tel qu'il y a 20
ans
vous êtes très digne de confiance avant tout nous avons
au contrat notre tasse du conteneur
les garçons sur Delano le chat  alyst un
transitoire nous voyons le contrat LED
Arkansas chercher l'Amérique pour virus Donna
Allah stocke généralement la famille autour de certains
corrigeant d'autres déjà son bureau tout
doux aujourd'hui des entreprises comme mackovic
construction ont des règles très strictes pour
adopter une personne qui était ce mur
sauf si vous avez un confirmé  Darla VR
vient bientôt de côté les spectacles de Philemon sont
la compagnie de diesel mackovic a refusé de
nous montrer son code de conduite tout comme les
autres grandes entreprises travaillant au Nunavik
une chose pénible
levan journée difficile Adams FC NQ construction
seulement WSP nous a envoyé ses directives toutes
ces entreprises  a refusé notre demande d'
interviews pour le salut Atlanta
si une entreprise enfreint les règles, son permis
est retiré c'est ce qui est arrivé à EDC
nord oui - TV - la deuxième partie est déjà une
livraison familiale - oui mais ils ont trouvé
le respect répondu s'il fallait poursuivre votre
hop  -up à Houston il à la fois vous étiez dans
un stade
si vis-à-vis des travailleurs de pacemí beaucoup Bob à avoir
dans l'avion qui est ultra grand le
sur  Ly Padonia me dit que les deux sont très faciles
nous avons contacté le président de l'usine EDC nord
Stephan il a refusé de répondre à nos
questions concernant le comportement de certains
de ses employés l'entreprise a fait
faillite en 2017
il y a trois ans une autre entreprise gen de
notre construction dessinait également des
indésirables  attention au nunavik dans le
petit village de clock tack certains de ses
ouvriers avaient saccagé le
camp de construction lors d'une soirée bien arrosée nous avons atteint un
D'Amico Lula et Bertha Adams à Clarke les
propriétaires du camp loué par la police
ont été convoqués
nous avons parlé à Jennifer  construction ils
confirment l'incident ils disent que
des mesures disciplinaires ont été prises avec
certains employés et d'autres ont été licenciés
ils ont affirmé qu'il n'y avait pas de mineurs sur les
lieux
toutes les femmes à qui nous avons parlé avaient quelque chose
à dire sur les travailleurs qui viennent au nord Ava
Abraham vit à Salawat depuis
26 ans je vois que chaque année comme même les
jeunes femmes les jeunes ados elles se
trompent comme les trompes concernant l'alcool
je portais mon gi  rls de ne pas être autour d'un
engin homme embrasse je ne veux pas
qu'ils se blessent comme sa fille
aînée ma fille aînée a été invitée
l'année dernière à je ne sais pas si elle a eu des relations sexuelles
avec ces hommes mais quelques jours plus tard j'ai
découvert  qu'elle était qu'il y avait un
camp de construction après qu'elle était là-bas
elle était ivre tout l'été je ne l'ai
pas beaucoup vue l'année dernière est-elle
séparée de 28 vous venez parce que tôt mr.
dickerson est l'hypothèse Vasudev sont des
leurres au début
hulusi savage 'est le maire de Salawat il est
conscient des dommages que certains
travailleurs font dans sa communauté et il
aimerait y mettre un terme
alors nous avons exhorté la construction ou toute personne
qui a déménagé à le vendre travailler  ici pendant plusieurs
jours minimum,
nous espérons juste qu'ils vont faire
pourrait être une bonne action ici et vous pouvez
simplement vous concentrer sur le réseau et non sur les
personnes solutées ou les communautés ou les
petites filles excusez la cousine Kelly essayez
la construcción de Jean de santis RTD
Charlemagne  tout comme cette foire sur sa
désorganisation de l'équité étaient les
vacances victorieuses à nous ayant le nombre d'enfants
de l'original comme je suis tellement Scala
[Musique]
laverna a pris est le troisième plus grand
village du Nunavut Alex et fitzy ont 30
ans et travaillent à  l'épicerie
il invite souvent de très jeunes collègues
chez lui sa femme est là mais elle
se couche tôt une fois seule p'tee donne de l'
alcool à ses jeunes invités en échange de
faveurs sexuelles ses victimes étaient 1  4 et 15
au moment où les abus ont duré six
mois, les deux adolescentes ont déposé une
plainte. petit a été accusé d'
agression sexuelle et de contacts sexuels sur des mineurs.
petit a plaidé coupable à gatineau aux
accusations réduites de contact sexuel et d'
agression armée
[Musique]
il a été condamné à 90 jours de prison
à purger les fins de semaine
aujourd'hui il est libre mais tout comme l'agresseur de Kathy
son nom est maintenant sur les
délinquants sexuels  registre pour une période de 10
ans the draggy Rondon
iterability avinasi fans okay la memoria de mano say
more dissonant ammoniac foo typique désolé
the credit option and man as a subsea
Kujawa
près de la côte d'ungawa en 2016 un
employé de cuisine au centre de santé de Tula - Vick
a été arrêté van Jodo 34 a été
accusé d'agression sexuelle sur deux femmes
âgées de 17 et 18 ans
il ne s'est pas présenté au tribunal et a fui le
Nunavik un mandat d'arrêt a été émis
contre lui en août  ust 2017 cinq mois
plus tard, en janvier, il a été arrêté par la
police de Montréal, il a de nouveau été libéré lors d'
une audience après avoir versé une
caution de deux cents dollars, son procès est prévu pour
juillet, il a été assigné à résidence à
Montréal, mais lorsque nous avons visité son
appartement, il n'y avait pas  un vivant là-bas,
nous avons appris depuis que van Jodo a été
arrêté à Montréal le 24 février
et fait face à de nouvelles accusations d'agression sexuelle
sur un mineur et de cas d'enlèvement.
Le masque de Mallory est sur le point d'être
fait maintenant pour les dirigeants idiots du Québec ooh
déformation également plus présente ne laissez pas la
formation dans Potter trop devrait être
elle savait que nous ne pourrions être qu'un redémarrage d'un
personnel de Mopar kinesins Même la mesure extrême de Yoda
expose la raison ouais maintenant 11
régions de mascottes dans  Grandville qui a
séduit l'homme afghan même Bonanza qui
n'est pas un étudiant d'élite pop, le Nunavik pourrait-il
être un terrain de jeu pour les devi  fourmis
eske soutien à une piscine d'hôtel
la recette le remplissage de sédiments en
décembre 2017 le limoneux -
Groupe d'étude spécial du Québec ciblant l'
exploitation sexuelle des enfants en ligne a arrêté
Padraig REMIC de 29 ans à Sherbrooke
l'homme fait face à des accusations de possession et
distribution de pornographie juvénile  remet
travaillé un temps au centre de réhabilitation des jeunes de Salawat la
police a lancé un appel
au public dans l'espoir de recueillir plus d'
informations sur lui sans succès
Western 21st century P honneur d'amener à
savoir si c'était une personne personne s'il fallait
me voir n'en doute pas PC  renverser WA
Becky à la seconde elle est revenue si je fais
partie de la police très haut l'
autre police avisée pieuse suffisamment
entreprises d'une pétition manuels de lamentation pas de
police boscorelli qui CVC la police qui
voit les fétiches venir donc Astro voir division
convaincu EP Bascom donc  supposons qu'ils
contactent le Guzman confesseur
chef de la police du nunavik carte de mission merci confirme
qu'il y a actuellement des policiers
sous Inve  stigations
népalais un pauvre exactement tu sais
que l'avion est via une certaine politique
boutique important sexuel adulte la
politique
attends d'accord donne-moi non non d'accord
avec un peu de poids inuit sevilla nom de
cause ma mère tu sais faire la réalité
des jeunes filles et des femmes au Nunavik  c'est
radicalement différent de la vie dans le
sud jenny pucks lee une chasseuse de caribou passionnée a
terminé ses études dans le
sud et travaille maintenant avec des jeunes dans le
nord c'est la même province mais c'est
comme si on vivait dans un autre pays une fois que vous
prenez cet avion vous arrivez ici  c'est
comme un pays différent, nous n'avons pas
les mêmes ressources que vous les
filles les filles sont moins respectées ici
vous pouvez exiger le respect mais il y
a beaucoup de filles qui ne sont pas respectées
pourquoi pas traitées avec respect et certaines filles
qui ne le font pas  Je ne sais même pas ce qu'est le respect
[Musique]
cette grand-mère dévouée jouant avec
son petit-fils est Annie Alec ooh en tant
qu'aînée, elle aide à porter le poids du
village de Salawat sur ses épaules née
dans un igloo  o et dans la pauvreté, elle a complété
un diplôme en éducation et travail social à
l'Université McGill dans les années 1990, elle était
directrice de l'école du village lorsqu'elle a
appris que 11 petites filles avaient été
agressées sexuellement par le chauffeur d'autobus scolaire.
a répondu que cela faisait partie de
la culture inuite, ils peuvent avoir l'air de doser la
mère Puma savait alors quelle est votre tournée
hôtel élémentaire génial majora est une
chatte à manipuler chien mais un homme oh mon dieu
pour avoir manqué mon directeur Hitler et oui
dans mon boa je n'ai jamais gagné ils peuvent  regarde
bien que le sperme ils puissent regarder ceux qui l'
aiment donc aucun qui n'aurait pas
pu perdre mon cœur depuis ce moment
Annie Alec qui a consacré sa vie à la
prévention et encourage les victimes à
signaler les agressions sexuelles c'est une
bataille constante dans le royaume
oh ha ni  attaque du lit à la maison et ils
font imaginer bien plus de t sait qui est
passé à cet imitateur igné d'Omaha mais
le jeton de filet maillant Maximo
no leona guillermo machado
monilinia Oxman ornement deli  neator Lord
Simon l'orne près de moi LLL notoire
Italie près du plus chaud de Martinelli pas
sahaja Floride tout Alec qui a
confié qu'elle aussi a été abusée par un homme blanc
malgré toutes les années passées par la douleur
est toujours intense
Jojo hahaha charmant je ne peux même pas
gérer Nani
[Musique]
salut mère naka aluminium comment vas-tu
mon jeune une nouvelle arène où je sais qu'il était au
courant moi une autre guerre quand j'avais 16 ans
c'était un pilote
comment nous parlons j'ai trouvé sur mon ami ouais
elle l'a elle a un petit ami le
manager  de la Compagnie de la Baie d'Hudson alors
elle m'a demandé d'aller avec elle je
ne savais pas qu'il y avait un homme un autre
homme c'était un homme blanc du sud
ce qui s'est passé après qu'il m'a déchiré
j'avais acquis pendant de nombreuses années de
travail  ouais ouais ce jour là Lizzy un
loofah est agent de prévention avec la
Catterick Regional Police Force elle est
aussi un pilier pour les femmes en UNIVAC c'est
dangereux d'être une fille ici es-tu d'accord
avec ça oui surtout si comme certaines
personnes qui ne sont pas de la c  la communauté
ou les gens ici que nous sommes des drogues
nous sommes toxicomanes lorsque vous récupérez nos
enfants nous laissons nos enfants seuls à la
maison beaucoup de gens savent que par non donc
je pense que certaines personnes qui viennent se sentent
libres et pensent que personne n'en entendra jamais
parler  ce qu'ils aiment, il y a de
petites communautés, cela pourrait arriver très
facilement.
Je sais qu'il y a des années, quand Hydro-Man
parcourait les rues à la recherche de femmes et que
certaines ont dû être renvoyées à cause de
leurs activités, Alyssia lupa est l'une
des femmes responsables du bien.  touch
bad touch programme qui apprend aux enfants
à dénoncer les comportements inappropriés
plus j'en parle plus je commence
à réaliser que nous devons choisir est-ce que nous restons
silencieux comme nous l'avons toujours été ou est-ce que nous
commençons à en parler et amener les gens à
commencer à en parler  ça aussi
parce qu'ici, les abus sexuels sont la
plus grande cause de suicides, je
crois vraiment qu'avec les membres de l'équipe avec
qui je travaille,
parler publiquement reste difficile
et ce n'est pas  toujours encouragée au
Nunavik nous avons rencontré une des jeunes leaders du Nunavik
elle voulait encourager les femmes à
dénoncer le comportement de certains travailleurs
son employeur lui a ordonné de se taire
ou éventuellement de perdre son
emploi elle nous a quand même envoyé ce message svp
organisation dirigez notre parti d'opposition
elle adore l'expérience  il propose une
solution
onaji suntrasoft est permis beaucoup des
plus négatifs le dépeint à l'occasion
un enseignant et Sol LeWitt a voulu
dénoncer le harcèlement que ses jeunes
élèves ont subi de la part de
certains ouvriers du bâtiment la
commission scolaire catholique a refusé de lui accorder
la permission  parler et personne
du conseil d'administration n'accepterait nos
demandes d'interview
chaque été des jeunes adolescentes viennent
passer quelques semaines dans ce camp de l'
autre côté de la crique
ici des anciens du village partagent avec
elles certaines valeurs et traditions vous
savez ce qu'il sait  il voudrait le
collectionner à la limite dans ton livre d'esprit tu
sais mais tu parlais de lui avec
lui  ou faites-le aller avec moi ou peu
de cela nous savions à quoi j'assiste Je me suis
rencontré dans votre truc intérieur jusqu'à se connecter
sur Capharnaüm Avonlea elle a pris une
belle journée souvenir Je sais qu'il y en a
eu il y a là-bas non non
il y a un  sortie vraiment
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas toujours disponible pour
tout le monde et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir rencontré mon amie elle était infirmière
en salaire elle a commencé à me faire comprendre que
ce n'est pas
bien tu es amené à être en ordre
[Musique]
car même à travers toutes les difficultés que
nous avons nous avons été résilients nous sommes forts
nous nous battons quoi qu'il arrive même si nous
sommes traités comme des chiens
parfois nous sortons toujours forts
êtes-vous fier d'être une femme anglaise
mille fois ouais ouais
toi